Hồi chứ kìa bước bắt đại tây dựng nha tồ đăng phải đối mặt với nhiều thích nước nội bộ
khi bộ trường của phòng bỷ, Joe Franken ngày 1 bộ thương tư truyết, nha tồ đăng kỷ niệm bệm biệnh bệnh năm
ngày thành lập trong bối cạnh, khăn thằng giữa các đường mấyng ở mức chưa từng cóo.
Ông cũng bày tỏ lo ngại, tổng thống như đôn nân trang có thể đón gửa các cân cú của Mỹ tại cho ông,
giúp cần được Mỹ, nướng trên sẻ thùng tình tình báo của những cách sạm cây nướng phổ chợo quan trọng khác.
Theo nhiều quần tình có tế, tình bố của tổng thống Mỹ đôn nân trang về khả năng cân nhắc dù Mỹ hỏi nât tồ,
đã làm ra tăng ám lực bờ bờ bờ bờ liền này.
Giờ Mỹ này sẽ giá lên quan tự xung đồ tại i fan khi Mỹ theo đồ ở lập trường tứng giắn,
trong khi Joe ủ tình hỏi sao và không sẵn sẵn sẵn thăm xa hỏa phụ trợ.
Theo dưới chứa xác có tế, giờ các biệt bây lợi ích và ủ tình ăn nên lạng,
nhưng nhân, kinh nât tồ hó vui trị dọng thậm thậm thủ đối,
để gặp đỏ vàn đây chiếc xe hảnh thức phòng tiếp tục là điểm thời chính luật.
Tì vậy, cảm nghĩ và cơ đồng mình chỗ ủ đều thương nhận
vai trò chính lúc của nât tồ đối với anh linh khu vực và tăng tồn,
nên bất kỷ điều trình nào lên quan đi bay trò của Mỹ trong nât tồ,
cũng sẽ cần được cân nhắc kỷ lượng.